important for Erik Jones.
We get Erik Jones, you get a mod
has everything. Let me take you
back to the beginning of this
game. What were you thinking
when you fell behind 10?
Nothing in that first quarter,
just come out and make a play,
get up on the board and
we know end up swinging some one
way or another. What's
the what's the most difficult
part about coming off a bye
trying
to plan a game like this?
You just a little rust, you
know, that's what I feel like
a little rusty.
You don't have that week of
practice that you have the two
weeks running up.
You're just coming back. People
are coming back on the plains
their vacations or whatever. It
may be. But I'm glad we came
out here and we didn't start as
fast as we wanted to. But
second half, we started fast
talk about Aaron Rodgers, man,
and what he's shown, you, I
mean, his toughness coming out.
If anybody ever
had a toe, they know how
difficult it is to run, not
only run play quarterback and
he's in these
frigid temperatures.
He's a, he's a true warrior.
He's our leader and we go as he
goes, you know. No, he may not
practice during the week, but
he lets us know. Hey,
I'm gonna be there again, that
he's out there with us at
practice. He's pushing us. He's
making sure we're getting
everything right, Peter? Bishop
leadership. And
when you got a great leader like
that, everything's going
to be good and you look like
you're flat space ship. Wearing
those Shades right there. Yeah.
Well, I better than
what you got there. These are
Oakley Kato. So
these are these are the new
versions this year.
The goal versions. They were
only handed out to
the Olympians who won. Metal. So
I was luckily lucky enough to
get a pair of man. You got to
talk to me about a J dilla. Now.
It seems like you've been
working with AJ Dylan because it
doesn't seem like they
changed the Playbook when they
put you or him in.
Yes. I we've been putting in a
lot of work
and that's something that we
want.
We don't want when he comes in,
or when I come in its
predictable, right? You can't
get a bead on us. You don't
know what's going on. He can do
the same things that I can and
I can do the same things that he
can't, and
it's been an honor to work with
him and he's getting better and
better each day. Okay. And
what's the fourth quarter? How
nice is it to have them in the
fourth quarter? And really
weird on that defense in the
fourth quarter, Bruiser is real
nice threat
in the fourth quarter. They
weren't down there. I want to
tackle him here. That's 250
running at you. He'll want to
do that.
And in partnership with your
twin brother Alvin,
you get the nod for Walter,
Payton Man of the Year. One of
the coolest awards at the NFL,
does what has your brother
meant to your football journey
and your life journey to my
brother. Matt has meant
everything,
especially after Mom my father's
past.
My brother contemplating giving
up football and just being
there for me,
but I told him, no, you know
what? That's
that's your dream. Don't give up
on your dream and Dad,
wouldn't want you to give up on
your dream. But that's just
a little bit about my brother.
He's everything to me. He died.
He only counties mrs. When he
was up in the CFL. He's been
here. Every step of the way.
He's been a think. He's one of
the reasons that I keep going.
He pushes me for me. It's a
pretty special place. I played
here but to look up in the
rafters and see rain, its key
and Bart
Starr. Our how does it feel for
you to see all these fans
yelling and screaming and
supporting their job bro. We
got the best fans in the world.
I can't say nothing, but we got
the best fans in the world.
I love playing here and land
boat. A tradition is nothing
like it and like I said, best
friends in the world and you
got this incredible partnership
friendship as well with Aaron
Rodgers. How is pairing with
him? Impacted your career?
Has made me the player. I am
today.
The one for a ride. I don't even
know if I would have seen
the Remember
when I was young my rookie year,
he turned to the salon.
I want 33 in the game and I
remember running on,
on the run into the game. On
first time is actually against
the Bears week for my rookie
year, and he tells me, I'm one
of your biggest fans in this
organization
and I'm like, wow, it in a
future Hall of Fame,
quarterbacks telling me this
epic rookie. Oh, it made me
feel like I could accomplish
anything and
it gave me a lot of confidence,
you know, as a like I said,
a future Hall of Famers telling
a rookie who hadn't taken
a single offense to snap this
and
It's definitely done a lot for
me and my career. Well, we
really appreciate you coming by
man. We're not going to hold
you out here. You know, you got
business to take care. Thank
you for today, and I'm a huge
fan of you.